ponle pausa al vídeo y calcula cuánto es
71 24 bueno ahora resolvamos este
cálculo juntos primero nos vamos a poner
a pensar en qué significa 71 y pues
podemos observar que tiene un 1 en el
lugar de las unidades este es el lugar
de las unidades
unidades ok tenemos una unidad y la
podemos ver por aquí
este es el 1 de 71 ahora en el lugar de
las decenas de cines y este es el lugar
de las decenas tenemos un 7 o sea que
tenemos 7 decenas y están por aquí
nuestras siete decenas tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete decenas
siete grupos de diez unidades
así es que esto de aquí tal cual
significa siete decenas y una unidad por
crear por aquí tenemos 71 cajitas y a
eso le vamos a sumar 24 no cree pero el
24 son dos decenas este es el lugar de
las decenas de escenas y las tenemos por
aquí una decena dos decenas
y 4 unidades
unidades y aquí están nuestras cuatro
unidades porque hay entonces cuánto es
esta suma
bueno pues podemos empezar pensando en
las unidades y pues tenemos una unidad y
luego tenemos otras cuatro unidades
entonces en total de todas estas
unidades podemos ponernos a contar
cuántas unidades son y pues son uno más
cuatro o sea cinco unidades y ahora pues
vamos a ver el lugar de las decenas
aunque yo empezamos con siete decenas y
le estamos sumando otras dos decenas y
entonces cuántas decenas tenemos en
total pues si juntamos todas estas
decenas
todas estas escenas tenemos nueve
decenas siete decenas más dos decenas
son nueve decenas así es que terminamos
con nueve decenas de
5 unidades y 5 unidades y bueno cual es
otra forma de decir 9 decenas y 5
unidades pues esa otra forma es decir 95
y listo ya terminamos